[موسيقى]
أول ما يتبادر إلى
أذهاننا هو القاعدة ،
كان هناك فهم
للتهديد ولكن لم يكن على رأس
قائمة أولويات أي شخص
[موسيقى] لقد
عانينا من خسارة كبيرة في حزننا
وغضبنا  وجدنا مهمتنا
ولحظتنا
في وكالة المخابرات المركزية ، كان الموقف هو أن
نضع بعض الرجال على طائرة هليكوبتر
ونطير إلى أفغانستان غدًا نعرف
كيف نغزو البلدان
للأسف
أراد طالبان
[موسيقى]
أولئك الذين يختارون العيش في حالة إنكار
قد يجبرون في النهاية على العيش  في خوف
وحققنا الأمر بشكل
جيد ، أشعر بالرعب لأنني كنت جزءًا منه
كارثيًا ،
لم يكن علينا أبدًا السماح لتلك
الخلافة بتأسيس
أسادو
[موسيقى]
كنا دائمًا نتبعه من أجل
إنشاء أرشيف كبير له  صور
لذلك اليوم
كان لدي كاميرتي الخاصة
وأردت
فقط التقاط المقابلة ،
كنا أربعة أشخاص ، أنا
صديق آخر ،
وسألهم الزعيمان من
أنت ، كيف أتيت إلى
أفغانستان ، ما نوع الأسئلة التي
لديهم على الأقل سؤال واحد  كان السؤال هو أنك
إذا استولت على أفغانستان ، فما الذي
ستفعله مع القاعدة وقائد
القاعدة
وكنت مشغولاً بالكاميرا الخاصة بي ربما لمدة
15 و 20 و 30 ثانية
حتى سمعت
صوت انفجار لم يكن الصوت قوياً
فقط.  كما لو كانت كرة القدم تنفجر ،
فعندما أنظر إلى الوراء إلى
المبنى رأوا أن جميع الأبواب
والنوافذ قد تحطمت هناك
كنت مع جدتي كنت جالسًا
معها وكنا نتناول طعامًا
كانت أختي
معنا أيضًا
وأنا  التقطت ملعقة لتناول الطعام
ثم سقطت من يدي
وفجأة كان هناك اندفاع من
التوتر والأدرينالين والأوعية
الدموية
واه
عبثًا وكنت
خائفة جدًا وخائفة
وسألتني جدتي ما الذي يحدث  لقد قلت إنني
لا أعرف ولكن لدي هذا
الشعور الغريب الذي حدث لأبي
في اللحظة المحددة عندما وقع الهجوم
والانفجار على بعد
مئات الأميال والكيلومترات
من مكان حدوثه
[موسيقى] هبطت
المروحية
رأينا الضخم  مبنى المستشفى وكان
هناك مبنى آخر على بعد
هو المشرحة والسيارة
بدلاً من التوجه نحو المستشفى ،
تحولت إلى العلامة
وأعلم أنه في ذلك الوقت
لم يعد على قيد الحياة
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كانت القاعدة تفكر في أن
الاستفادة من الموقف
قالوا إنهم سيكون لديهم نوع من
القاعدة الدائمة في أفغانستان ، لذلك كان هناك هذا
الفكر كانت نفس
الأساليب التي كانت إلى حد ما هي نفسها [
موسيقى]
لذا
[موسيقى]
يا هراء
أم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى] أجنبية
واتصلت على الفور بمساعد
وزير مكافحة التجسس
وقلت إننا تعرضنا للهجوم
ثم اتصل نائب الرئيس بعد حوالي دقيقتين
وقال
من فضلك اذهب إلى غرفة المؤتمرات الآمنة التي
نحتاجها للحصول على فيديو  اتصل
لكنني
أدركت على الفور أنه في أعقاب
اغتيال أحمد شاه
مسعود ،
فإن الولايات المتحدة وأنا بالتأكيد
مذنب بفشل
الخيال
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
نعم بالطبع
كان هناك كانوا يستمعون
ولكن لا يوجد عمل
لذا فإن
الأشخاص المسؤولين عن تسعة وأحد عشر
هم نفس الأشخاص الذين تعرف أنهم
مسؤولون عن اغتيال والدي
عندما دخل هذان العربيان إلى
أراضينا ، كان ذلك قبل 15
يومًا تقريبًا
من التاسع من سبتمبر ، مما
يعني أن الخطة كانت
لمساعدة القائد في ذلك
إذا نجحوا في القيام بذلك قبل 9 سبتمبر ،
فسيكون
لديهم
وقت كاف
لتنظيف أفغانستان
قبل 11 سبتمبر.
يمكنني أن أخبرك أنه كان ممتعًا
لأنه عندما قُتل أحمد ،
كان الطالبان مبتهجًا للغاية  لقد اعتقدوا أن
هذا لا بأس به دون مسعود أخيرًا
سننتصر في الحرب وما إلى ذلك وما
إلى ذلك من
طالبان. لقد
جندت مصدرًا كان عضوًا في
القاعدة
لذلك قمنا بتجنيده بالكامل وذهب
للعمل لدينا
ثم كنت بعد ذلك.  أجبرني
المقر الرئيسي لوكالة المخابرات المركزية الأمريكية (سي آي إيه) على إجباري على قطع
الاتصال به والتوقف عن مقابلته
بشكل أساسي لأنه كان مواطنًا في
دولة تربطنا بها علاقات ودية
وكانوا أكثر قلقًا إذا تم
القبض علينا ونحن نقابل هذا الرجل
بشأن هذا الأمر الذي من المحتمل أن يؤدي إلى الإضرار
بالعلاقات الدبلوماسية  مما كانوا حول وجود
مصدر داخل القاعدة ،
لذلك اضطررت إلى قطع الاتصال
لا يمكن
[موسيقى]
عندما كان في أفغانستان ، كانت هناك
خطط تشغيلية كاملة مكتوبة داخل
وكالة المخابرات المركزية
للذهاب إلى أفغانستان
والتخلص منه من
الخطة الأصلية وهي
أننا  سوف نذهب إلى أفغانستان وسنقتل
هذا الرجل
لأنه يستعد لقتلنا
لأنه يقتلنا بالفعل
ولم تتم الموافقة على هذه النباتات أبدًا لأنه
كان هناك مع عائلته كان من الممكن أن
يكون هناك نساء وأطفال  كان من
المؤكد أن يقتل كجزء من
تلك العملية في
سبتمبر
اليوم على ركبتي منحنية
في الصلاة من أجل الأشخاص الذين
فقدوا أرواحهم هنا ،
يمكنني أن أسمعك يسمعك بقية العالم
يسمعك
والناس
والأشخاص الذين هدموا هذه المباني
سوف  اسمعنا جميعًا قريبًا في
اليوم التالي 9 11 بالتأكيد في غضون 24
48 ساعة من ذلك ،
عدت إلى مقر وكالة المخابرات المركزية
وأنت تعلم ، ثم كان هناك الكثير من
الغضب الذي
تبعه بسرعة كبيرة ،
هل يمكننا نزع القفازات الآن
ويمكننا ذلك  اذهب الآن وافعل كل الأشياء التي
كنا نحاول أن تجعلنا
نفعلها
كما لو كان قد فات الأوان ، فقد مات آلاف الأشخاص ،
لكن هل يمكن الآن أن يُسمح لنا أخيرًا بإنهاء
هذا
الفيديو ،
أتى شخص ما من مركز مكافحة الإرهاب
للتحدث إليه
وسألتني عما إذا كنت أعرف كيف يمكنهم
الاتصال بهذا الرجل وأين
يمكنهم العثور عليه ، وهو
سؤال مثير للسخرية ، صحيح أنه
كان إرهابياً ،
ولم يكن صديقي ،
ولم يكن أخي ،
ولم نبقى على اتصال اجتماعي
لم يكن يعرف اسمي الحقيقي أبدًا ، من الواضح
أنك لا تتسكع مع
مصادر إرهابية ، فأنت لا ترسل لهم بطاقات عيد الميلاد
حيث يكون جيدًا إذا كان بإمكاني تخمين أنه هناك
الآن ينظم
عمليات متابعة لقتل الأمريكيين هذا هو
تخميني
لدينا  وكالة استخبارات رائعة ،
ما زلنا لسنا أفضل استخبارات في
العالم ، ولماذا لأننا لسنا مضطرين لأن
نكون
إسرائيليين ، فنحن لا
نتعرض للهجوم من جميع الجوانب ، نحن
مجتمع ديمقراطي حر مفتوح مع
حدود مفتوحة إلى الجنوب
تعال إلى ما يمكن أن يحدث خطأ هنا
وفجأة نكتشف أن الشر
موجود أجنبي
عليك أن تتذكر في التسعينيات أننا كنا
نحتفل بعائد السلام ، لقد
سقط الجدار ،
قللنا من استخباراتنا أه
استثمار  أصبح تمويلنا
لمجتمع الاستخبارات لدينا فعّالاً بشكل كبير
وفجأة اكتشفنا من ليس لدينا عدد
كافٍ من المتحدثين باللغة الفارسية ، ليس لدينا ما
يكفي من المتحدثين باللغة الفارسية ، ليس لدينا
متحدثون باللهجة ،
نعم ليس لدينا ما يكفي مما نحتاج إليه.
إذا كنت محقًا ، فأنت تقول كل هذه الأشياء
وأعني أنه كان من الممكن منع 9 11 هجومًا
دون أدنى شك ، فقد كان من
الممكن منعها
[موسيقى]
لذا فقد
حول حزننا الغضب
والغضب إلى حل
سواء كنا نقدم أعداءنا
للعدالة أو نحقق العدالة لأعدائنا
ستتحقق العدالة ، كان القرار الأول
هو منح طالبان فرصة
لتسليم أسامة بن لادن
والقاعدة ، وكانت الرسالة الأولى
لطالبان في أفغانستان هي أنك إذا فعلت ذلك
يمكنك البقاء في السلطة ، فلديهم
مهلة قصيرة جدًا قدموها.  من الواضح أنهم
لن
يسلموا أيًا من قيادة القاعدة ،
ولذا فقد تبع ذلك حتمًا
أننا سنقوم بعمل عسكري ،
كل دولة
في كل منطقة لديها
الآن قرار تتخذه
إما أنك معنا
أو أنت مع  الإرهابيون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جاء لرؤيتي وأراد أن
يشرح لي أنه كان عليّ أن أفهم
تاريخ طالبان وما إلى ذلك
وقلت لا يوجد
تاريخ عام يبدأ اليوم
وهؤلاء هنا ستة  مطالب أو
سبعة مطالب أن السكرتير باول
وكتبنا أنفسنا على قطعة من الورق
وأعطيته إياه وقلت من فضلك
تواصل مع الرئيس ميشيل
وتحدث معه حول هذا ،
نحن بحاجة إلى نعم على كل منهم ، لا نعم
مايبس نعم ،
لقد كان غاضبًا جدًا  معي
وأستطعت أن أرى أنه كان مترددًا ،
فأخذته إلى مكتبي الخلفي
حيث
عرضت نجمة باكستانية على جائزة
أعطيت لي خلال
الحرب السوفيتية لدعم المجاهدين
من باكستان وقلت له هل
تعرف  ما هذا وقد قال بالطبع
إنه السيتاري الباكستاني وقلت
هذا صحيح وإذا لم توافق على
مطالبنا فلن يتلقى أي أمريكي أيًا
منها مرة أخرى ، أعدك في
اليوم التالي الذي جاء فيه وقال إن
الرئيس مشرف وافق  مع
كل ما
قدمه الجنرال مشرف كانت
الرسالة التي نقلها الجنرال
محمود هي أن أه كنت معنا أو
سنقصفك إلى العصر الحجري في
الأشهر اللاحقة
أه يمكنني أن أخبرك أن علاقتي
مع ISI  قامت المخابرات الباكستانية
بتحويل 180 درجة إلى
أي شيء نريده فيما يتعلق
بالقاعدة التي
سيعطوننا إياها وتعاوننا بشكل
وثيق للغاية
ولكن هذه القواعد نفسها لم تطبق
وفعل شيئًا لم أره من قبل من قبل
زعيم قبلي.  افعل قبل أن
يخلع عمامته
ويضعها على الطاولة بجانبه
وبدا ميئوسًا منه لأنه كان يعلم
ما هي الكارثة التي ستقع
عليهم إذا ذهبوا إلى الحرب مع الولايات المتحدة
وقال
أخبرني ماذا علي أن أفعل  .
لذلك قلت انظروا ، نحن نعلم أن عمر لا يستطيع
لأسباب عديدة أنه لا يستطيع الانفصال عن
بن لادن ، لكن يمكنك أن
تفعل ما لا يستطيع الملا عمر أن يفعله
لك لإنقاذ الحركة ، ولا أحد
يقول أنه يجب عليك أن تؤذي الله.  عمر
ولكن عليك أن تضعه قيد
الإقامة الجبرية ، فأنت بحاجة إلى إصدار
بيان علني على الفور يوضح ما
تفعله ولماذا أه تحتاج إلى حشد
بقية أعضاء مجلس الشورى الذي تحتاجه
ولأننا مررنا بكامل
هذه الطريقة في الأساس  هل تقوم بانقلاب
واستمع إلي
فقال حسنًا سأفعل ذلك وكان الأمر
كما لو تم رفع ثقل عن
كتفيه ثم قفز في
مركباته وانطلقوا وعادوا إلى
قندهار
لذلك كنت آمل على عدم الأمل في ذلك  أنت
تعلم أن عزمه سينجو من الرحلة
إلى قندهار ، لكنني كنت أخشى ألا يحدث ذلك
وفي الحقيقة لم تبدأ
[الموسيقى] في
التنفيذ ،
كان روزفيل غاضبًا من الجيش
لعدم قدرته على إرسال قوات برية كبيرة
إلى أفغانستان في الوقت المناسب
كابول جاهزة للسقوط وليس لدينا
أي شخص هناك في وكالة المخابرات المركزية ، كان
الموقف هو أننا
سنضع بعض الرجال على متن طائرة هليكوبتر
ونطير إلى أفغانستان غدًا
مثل دعنا نذهب لا نهتم لسنا
بحاجة إلى مئات الرجال فلنذهب وفي
الحقيقة  هذه هي الطريقة التي بدأ بها الغزو في الواقع
حيث يعرف الجميع الآن
مروحية روسية قديمة وحوالي ثمانية
رجال من المخابرات المركزية
ويسافرون بأكياس من المال للتحدث إلى
مجموعة من زعماء القبائل الذين
لحسن الحظ أننا حافظنا على اتصال
مع الأجانب خلال
العملية العسكرية للعملية العسكرية ncia  التي هزمت طالبان
واستولت على كابول
هي على الأرجح العملية العسكرية الأمريكية الأكثر ذكاءً
منذ
الحرب العالمية الثانية التي
تم تنفيذها بشكل صحيح تمامًا في رأيي ، إلا أن قلة
قليلة جدًا من الأمريكيين
الحلفاء القبليين من القوات الجوية الأمريكية تم
تدمير طالبان.
[موسيقى]
حتى عام 2004 كان الوضع
يتحسن ، يمكنك السفر من هنا إلى أي
جزء من البلاد
لم يكن هناك
منطقة تحت سيطرة طالبان
والاكين هو
النواب بنفسي والآخرين لم يكن من
المفترض أن يذهبوا إلى غابات الذئب وقد ذهب
وتحدث  أمام
الرئيس قائلاً:
العراق يجب أن نستغل هذا
كفرصة للعراق ،
والتفت الرئيس إلى مستشارة الأمن القومي
فقالت له من هو نائب
وزير الدفاع ،
وقال حسنًا أخبرهم بذلك.  اصمت ،
لا أريد أن أسمع عنها بعد الآن ،
فنحن نركز على مؤتمر أفغانستان ،
تلقيت تعليمات للبحث عن
سفير العراق لدى الأمم المتحدة
لقراءته
نقاط الحديث التالية ، ثم
أعطوني بعض النقاط الحادة للغاية
بالنسبة لسفير العراق الذي
قال بشكل أساسي أنه
إذا كنت تفكر حتى في
الاستفادة
من انشغالنا الحالي
بأفغانستان ،
فيمكنك أن تكون على يقين من أننا سنتخذ إجراءات صارمة للغاية
ضدك ، لقد كانت
رسالة خطيرة للغاية
إنها أكتوبر 2001 وهذه
الإدارة تفكر بالفعل في
العراق  وبصراحة أعتقد أنهم يبحثون
عن طرق لإلقاء اللوم على العراق بسبب ما
حدث ، فقد
اتخذ بالفعل قرار
رئيس الولايات المتحدة بوش بأننا
سنغزو
ذلك ، وأعني أن الطريقة التي أقولها بالضبط
أننا لن نغزوها أو
إذا كانت هناك أسلحة دمار شامل
سوف تغزو
الآن القرار قد اتخذ سنقوم
بالغزو
لذا كانت مهمتي أن أضم الفريق الأول
للإعداد
لغزو العراق
صغير جداً
بحلول منتصف عام 2002
أه لم يكن هناك  سألني
أنه كان هناك تخطيط
لغزو ،
لكننا استمررنا في محاولة
تجنب
الحرب وعدنا من أجل هذا القرار النهائي
الذي
أخبرنا ببعض الأشياء ومن بين
الأشياء التي أذهلتني قليلاً
أننا لن نتردد في
تشويه سمعتك لصالح نزع السلاح ،
لقد كان كتابيًا قليلاً ولكن
المعنى الذي
أدركناه لاحقًا هو أنه إذا لم
تعثر على الأسلحة وتنقب عنها ، فسنقوم
بنزع سلاح العراق
بأنفسنا ،
الأسلحة الكيماوية ليست بلدي.  مربى البرتقال ،
يمكنك تتبعه ،
لذا يجب أن يكون لديك سجلات لذلك ، ولكن
بعد ذلك عندما وصلنا إلى قصر السلام في
إحدى
عمليتي التفتيش هناك وذهبنا
في كل مكان
وفتح المفتشون الثلاجات ،
وجدوا فقط مربى البرتقال لا توجد مواد كيميائية
شرائط فقط مربى البرتقال ألفريدو
[تصفيق]
أه
لم أكن غاضبًا من دومينيك على
الإطلاق لم يخبرنا شيئًا ما
لم يكن صحيحًا
بالنسبة لي ، لم
يكن هناك مفاجأة في طريق دومينيك ديفيل
وأعطيته الفضل في أنه كان لديه
الشجاعة
لإخبارنا
[موسيقى]
قال حسنًا إنهم يعتقدون أنك جواسيس جواسيس
لا يحبونهم لأنك
تعرف رئيسك في العمل ، باول ،
حسنًا ، لذا فأنت تخبرني أنه
لا يمكننا التحدث بعد الآن ،
نريد التحدث قال العقيد  بالنسبة لي ،
نريد أن نتحدث ،
نحن بحاجة إلى التحدث ،
لكن
وزير الدفاع أخبرنا أنه لا يمكننا ذلك ،
لذا أدركت أن جزءًا منها ، إن لم يكن
جزءًا كبيرًا منه ، كان يتحدثون
عن سوريا وكانوا يتحدثون عن
العراق وكانوا يتحدثون  حول إيران
وكان هناك تخطيط للحرب لتلك
البلدان ولم يريدوا منا أن
نجد
[موسيقى]
أجنبية ،
قال بصراحة
عفواً ، لكن يبدو أن كلامًا هراءًا ،
لذا سأخرج إلى وكالة المخابرات المركزية
وأقضي العديدة التالية  هناك أيام من
البحث في كل جزء من
المعلومات الاستخباراتية
للتأكد من أنها تقف
لصالحنا
عندما خرجت إلى هناك ، لم يكن لدي
خبير استخبارات خبير استخبارات محترف لأخبر جورج تينيت بأن
يخدع نفسه ، فأنت تعلم أنك
مخطئ جورج آسف دعني أخبر  أنت لماذا
أنت مخطئ
لذلك فشلت هناك
ثم ذهبت إلى وكالة المخابرات المركزية وعشت
هناك
لمدة ستة أيام وستة ليالٍ ،
وكان فريقي يتألف من كاتب خطابات
لين ديفيدسون
باري لوهان كرون وعضو سابق في
مجلس المخابرات الوطني وجورج
رفض اليوم الأول منحي أي
وصول إلى أجهزة الكمبيوتر الخاصة بوكالة المخابرات المركزية ،
لذلك اتصلت باري وقلت باري ، ما
زلت تحصل على بطاقتك وما زلت تقرأها ،
قال إنني لا أعرف دعنا نرى أنه
جلس في المحطة فحص في لعبة البنغو هو  ما زلت
في الداخل ، فقلت
لك إصبعك الأوسط للمستأجر وكنا هو من
توقف عن الكلام وكانت الغرفة
هادئة للغاية وأنا
جالس إلى يساره ومعتقداته
جالسة على يمينه
وأدار رأسه نحو تينيت
وقال
جورج أنت تضمن  أنا
أن كل شيء في هذا العرض
هو أفضل ما يمكنك فعله ،
ونظر إليه المستأجر وقال
نعم أفعل ، ثم قال بال حسنًا
لأنك ستكون ورائي
غدًا في الكاميرا
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
سدوم حسين ونظامه  مشغول
ببذل كل ما في وسعهم
للتأكد من أن المفتشين ينجحون في
العثور على أي شيء على الإطلاق
دومينيك ديفيد
جلست أمامه من على الطاولة
وأتذكر جيدًا أنني
شعرت بتشكيك متزايد حيال ذلك
لأنه لم ينسجم على الإطلاق مع تجربتنا التي
رسمناها.  ما
أفادت به مصادرنا عن هذه المرافق المتنقلة
هنا ، ترى كلاً من
المصانع المتنقلة المثبتة على الشاحنات وعربات السكك الحديدية ،
فنحن نعرف كيف تبدو المخمرات ، ونحن نعرف
كيف تبدو ضواغط مضخات الخزانات
والأجزاء الأخرى ،
كيف تعرف هذه الأشياء التي
أخبرتك بهذه الأشياء
و  لماذا لا يمكننا العثور على أي من
الأشياء نفسها التي نحن هنا طوال اليوم كل يوم
شهرًا بعد شهر بعد شهر على التوالي بحلول
الوقت الذي انتهينا فيه من
مئات المصادر
ولكن لا يمكننا العثور عليها ولكن هناك شيء واحد يمكنني أن
أؤكده لك
هو  لم يكن لديه نية لخداع أي شخص ،
لم يكن هناك نية لخداعه ، لقد
كان
يتصرف ببساطة بناءً
على
معلومات خاطئة وغير صحيحة ،
يقول إنها وصمة عار في سجله والتي لن
تختفي أبدًا ، إنه ليس إيديث بيا إذا
لم تندم على ريهانا
إنه نادم
على هذا
التصوير
[موسيقى]
حتى في
شباط (فبراير)
لم أتمكن من الوقوف وقلت أنه
لا توجد أسلحة يمكنني أن أقول 700
عملية تفتيش لذلك لم نعثر على أي شيء وهؤلاء
محترفون
كان يخشى إيران
وكان يعتقد أن إيران ستستفيد
منه وهذا ما  كانت في
هذه الساعة
القوات الأمريكية وقوات التحالف في
المراحل الأولى من العمليات العسكرية
لنزع سلاح العراق لتحرير شعبه
والدفاع عن العالم من
خطر جسيم
أجنبي
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
يا [
تصفيق]
سارت الأمور بسرعة كبيرة وكانت
توقعت أن الحملة ستسير
عسكريًا بسرعة كبيرة وكان
السؤال الكبير جيدًا ما الذي سيأتي بعد أن
أتذكر أنني اتصلت برئيسي بالجنرال ذو الثلاث نجوم
قائد الفيلق وقلت لدي
أخبار جيدة وأخبار سيئة ، قال ما هي
الأخبار السارة وأنا  قال الخبر السار
هو اننا نتحكم في الغثيان فقال
مبروك رهيبة ما هي الاخبار السيئة
قلت اننا نتحكم في نجيف ماذا تريد
منا ان نفعل به
اين هؤلاء الرجال الذين اخبرونا في
الكويت انك فقط اوصلتنا الى بغداد
ونحن؟  سأأخذها من هناك ، قال
حسنًا ، اتصل بهم
وقالوا إنهم ما زالوا منظمين ، وهذا يعني أنه
لا توجد سلطات عراقية
هناك لمساعدتنا في
[الموسيقى] ،
اعتقد الجميع أن جورج بوش كان بطلاً
وحوالي أسبوع  بعد ذلك
بدأ النهب وأدرك مواطنو العراق أنه
لا توجد سلطة ولا سلطة وهذا
عندما بدأت مشاكلنا بالفعل
[الموسيقى] هم
الذين أقنعوا الرئيس
بأنه يتحمل مسؤوليات قوة احتلال
بموجب اتفاقيات جنيف
وبموجب القانون الدولي.
أنه يجب أن يبقى ثم يتم
اختيار جيري بريمر ويدخل جيري
بريمر ليكون القنصل المحترف
وما إلى ذلك وهكذا دواليك
بول بريمر لديه دبلوماسية لأنني
كنت حاضرًا في اجتماع
قبل غزو العراق مع
الرئيس بوش.  الذي اتخذه
الرئيس أولاً هو أننا
سنحلل
إلى مستوى معين فقط ، وكان القرار الثاني
هو أننا في الواقع
من طائرة عسكرية أسقطنا منشورات
تحت الجنود وقال إن جنود
الجيش العراقي
سيعودون إلى ديارهم
وسوف نعاود الاتصال بك
كأحد الأشياء الأولى  فعل بريمر عندما
كان في العراق بطريقة ما استدار
حول هذين القرارين
وألغاه ، لقد حظر الجيش بالكامل وأتذكر
أحد الكولونيلات
قال لي هل
تعرف ماذا
يعني ذلك أن
شيئًا مثل 50000 حارس جمهوري
عاد الجنود إلى منازلهم بأسلحتهم
وقالوا إنني الآن أعارض
الحكومة
تلقائيًا تمامًا كما فعل جيري لدرجة أنني
تلقيت الأمر
قبل مغادرتي
واشنطن
وأبلغتني وزارة الدفاع بأن
الأمر قد تم تنسيقه بالكامل في الداخل
يدلي الناس في [الموسيقى] في حكومة الولايات المتحدة بتصريحات كاذبة حول هذا
الأمر ، ويقولون إن هذا
الأمر قد أدى إلى انهيار الحكومة العراقية ، وهذا هراء ، فقد تم تصميم الأمر للتأثير
فقط على
اثنين في المائة من أعضاء الحزب في الواقع ، كانت
إحدى النتائج  أن
معلمي المدرسة طردوا جميعًا من
معلمي المدرسة الذين تعرفهم ، وكان عليهم الانضمام إلى
حفلة الاستحمام لكي يصبحوا معلمين
تعلمون أنهم لم يكونوا تهديدًا إلى حد كبير
ولكن لم يتم تعليم الأطفال في
المدرسة لأن المعلمين
كانوا  جدلًا ، لذا كان الأمر حقًا
أه
كان حقًا كارثة
لدراسة
الجلوس هناك ، مما جعل الأمر
غير مريح بعض الشيء لأننا في الأساس
كنا نقول أن السياسات التي
يتبعها السيد بريمر هي
كارثة وهذا ما هم عليه
يقودنا إلى
أم
ولكننا قدمنا ​​ذلك الإيجاز إلى
الرئيس ونظر الرئيس إلى
بريمر وأتذكر
أنه قال ما قلته بالأمس وما
قلته بريمر
واه السيد بريبر قال
إنني لا أرى أي طريقة  إلى الأمام
بخلاف الخطوط التي نتابعها
الآن
واه
كانت نهاية الاجتماع
وسارت الأمور من هناك وكان ذلك
بالفعل مصدر
الأعداد الكبيرة الأصلية من الأفراد
الذين سيصبحون متمردين أو
متطرفين
مشيرًا إلى أنك  كان هناك البعض الآخر
بالطبع الذين أصبحوا أكثر حقًا
الذين أصبحوا حقيقيين من قبل القاعدة
في العراق بقيادة الزرقاوي في البداية بالطبع
حتى وفاته في عام 2006.
لكن
كان
هذا هذان القراران كارثيان حقًا
ويمثلان انتكاسات
لم نتمكن من تحقيقها أبدًا.  أتعافى تمامًا وأنا
أحترم
الجنرالات الأمريكيين الذين يعتقدون أن
هذا كان خطأً لكنهم لم يتحملوا
المسؤولية التي كانت تتحملها وهي أن
أفعل ذلك بشكل صحيح وقد
جعلنا جميعًا
أعيننا
عن الكرة
والبعض
الآخر في  بدأت الإدارة في منتصف عام
بالتفكير في العراق
ووضعنا أفغانستان
بصراحة على طيار آلي
ووجهنا انتباهنا إلى العراق
وغادرنا أفغانستان
مثل هذا
أوباما [
الموسيقى]
دفع باراك أوباما 30 ألف جندي إلى
أفغانستان وقال بعد
18 شهرًا من الآن نحن  يتم
سحبهم ،
حسنًا ، من
الواضح أن هذا أمر مثير للسخرية ، أعني
عدم إرسالهم أو إرسالهم وإخبارهم
بالعودة إلى المنزل عند الانتهاء من الوظيفة التي تم شغلها ،
دعني على الفور أقول
إن باكستان اتخذت
قرارًا مدروسًا
جزء من التحالف
ليكون مع الولايات المتحدة لمحاربة
الإرهاب
بجميع أشكاله
أينما كان.
في الوقت نفسه ،
كانت عناصر معينة من القوات المسلحة الباكستانية تدعم
طالبان ، لكن إذا نظرت إلى الأمر من
وجهة نظرهم ،
فإنهم كانوا يحمون
أنفسهم لأنهم لم يكونوا
متأكدين مما سيحققه المستقبل 100
تعاون
بالتأكيد لم يأتِ أبدًا من باكستان
ودولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة.  كان خطأ إدارة الأدغال هو
الاعتقاد بأنها ستكون
عملية تدريجية ، كانوا سعداء بتعاون 30٪ و 40
٪ في البداية ،
ثم 50٪ لم يفهموا أبدًا
أنه طالما أنه ليس 100٪ ،
فإنه سوف يجدد نفسه.
لا يمكننا أن ننتصر في الحرب في أفغانستان ،
أقول إنك انتصرت في الحرب في أفغانستان بعد
حوالي خمسة أشهر من ذلك ،
وقد تم تحقيق جميع أهدافك
جميعًا ،
ثم توصلت إلى خطة جديدة تمامًا
لتحويل أفغانستان
إلى سويسرا في وسط آسيا.
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أجنبي
دول مختلفة في المنطقة
لذلك
شجعوا
المتطرفين على القدوم
من كل
الدول المختلفة
لدخول العراق وزودوهم
بمئات
أو آلاف السيارات المفخخة
ونجح المتطرفون في
إثارة
التوتر الطائفي بين  العراقيون
[الموسيقى]
ما جعل زيادة القوات ناجحة
لم يكن زيادة القوات ، بل كانت
زيادة الأفكار بل كانت الطريقة التي غيرنا بها
استراتيجيتنا
وتكتيكاتنا على الأرض
وكل ذلك كان مختلفًا بمقدار 180 درجة
عما كنا نفعله
من قبل  بالنسبة إلى زيادة القوات ، من
الواضح جدًا لنا
أننا بحاجة إلى العودة إلى
الأحياء أنه كان علينا تأمين
الناس ويمكننا فعل ذلك فقط من خلال
العيش مع الناس
هنا
[موسيقى] [موسيقى
]
كان حسين [موسيقى] كارثيًا  الخطأ هو
ما نطلق عليه خطأ غير قابل للتحلل البيولوجي ،
فهو لن يختفي أبدًا ،
ربما سيكون هناك نصف عمر في
مرحلة ما ، لكن تلك الصور ،
تلك الصور ، لا تزال
موجودة على الإنترنت بسهولة شديدة ،
وسيظل ذلك حافزًا
لأولئك الذين  تريد انتقاد
الولايات المتحدة
لتوليد الدعم
للأنشطة المتطرفة وقد حفزت
العرب السنة على وجه الخصوص
مرة أخرى لمحاربة الولايات المتحدة
في السنوات التي تلت ذلك
لم يكتشف من قبل في تاريخ أمريكا
حيث أذن رئيس الولايات المتحدة
ببشر.  أن نتعرض للتعذيب
وهذا ما فعله جورج دبليو بوش
تحت التأثير الكبير لنائب
الرئيس ديك تشيني ومستشاره
ديفيد أدينغتون ، لقد انتهكنا القانون المحلي ،
لقد انتهكنا القانون الدولي بالتأكيد
عندما عذبنا الناس ،
لم تتحقق أية مساءلة ،
فهم مجرمو حرب إذا حدث ذلك.  يعني أنني سأذهب
إلى السجن كمجرم حرب
طالما ذهبوا إلى السجن كمجرمي حرب ،
سأكون سعيدًا
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
أتذكر في أغسطس أنه سار عبر
الباب إلى مكاتبنا وقال هل
سمعت آخر
لا يزال جورج يحصل على هذه الصور
على
موقعه على الويب ، لقد قلت الصور الصور قال
نعم صور المعامل البيولوجية المتنقلة
أنها لا تزال موجودة
وقلت جيدًا من الواضح أن جورج لا يزال
يعتقد أنها كانت
مختبرات بيولوجية متنقلة وقال باول
حسنًا أعتقد أن هذا  المحطة الوحيدة في عرضي
التقديمي التي لا تزال قائمة لأن جميع
الآخرين قد تم حذفهم على
مدار الصيف بعد
أسبوع ، وعاد وقال إن
جورج اتصل بي للتو ، وقد
انهارت ساقي الأخيرة ،
ولم تكن هناك مختبرات بيولوجية
وأنا جالس  هناك تفكير
جيدًا ، فأنت تعرف أنك وأنا على حد سواء
ساذجان لأن الجحيم هذه هي
المشكلة الحقيقية ، نحن ساذجون مثل
الجحيم.  من
المؤكد أنهم
اتبعوا
أنشطة طائفية فظيعة أدت
مرة أخرى إلى
نفور العرب السنة مرة أخرى
وجعلتهم يشعرون بأنهم محرومون من ممتلكاتهم ومنحتهم مرة
أخرى حافزًا في
فشل العراق الجديد بدلاً من
نجاحه وبالطبع كان ذلك هو الذي
سمح
للقاعدة في العراق الآن  دولة إسلامية
تعيد بناء نفسها
للانجراف إلى سوريا للحصول على
قوة قتالية إضافية ثم العودة إلى
العراق وتسبب مشاكل كبيرة في
إنشاء خلافة كان لها الموصل
مقرها في الشمال أه
وبالطبع الرقة مقرها في
سوريا
[موسيقى  ]
[الموسيقى] الخاص بي
أعتقد أنه
ربما كان السؤال الأكبر بينهم جميعًا
لماذا
قرروا الذهاب إلى العراق
وأعتقد أنه لا يزال
المجهول الكبير
لماذا بالكاد
يستطيع صدام فعل أي شيء
لم يكن يمثل تهديدًا لأي شخص في ذلك الوقت
لذلك
لا أعرف أي شخص يمكنه إعطائك
إجابة مقنعة على هذا السؤال ،
ما زال بعضهم يعتقد أن هناك
أسلحة ، عفواً ،
هذا جنوني ،
عفواً [
تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سأدعم وأدافع عن
[الموسيقى]
عندما أصبح  مدير وكالة المخابرات
المركزية ، أحضرني الرئيس إلى المكتب البيضاوي وقال
إن
إحدى
أهم أولوياتي
كانت ملاحقة بن لادن
ونتيجة لذلك جمعت فرقة عمل
في وكالة المخابرات المركزية
لأفعل شيئًا آخر غير ملاحقة بن
لادن.  لقد قلت أن هذه هي مهمتك الرئيسية
وعليك أن تبلغني كل أسبوع بما يحدث
كنا نراقب المجمع
وكان هناك هذا
الشخص في منتصف العمر الذي كان
يخرج مثل سجين في
ساحة السجن وكان يفعل  تمشي في دوائر
بسرعة كبيرة ثم عاد إلى
الداخل وأتذكر أنني أخبرت وكالة المخابرات المركزية
أنه يجب عليك الحصول على هوية وجه يمكن أن يكون بن لادن
آه وقالوا أنك تعرف
السيد المدير
هناك جدران يبلغ ارتفاعها 18 قدمًا
12  - جدران الأقدام لا يمكننا حقًا الحصول على
لقطة جيدة ، لقد قلت لهم جميعًا ،
قلت إنك تعلم أنني شاهدت أفلامًا حيث
يمكن لوكالة المخابرات المركزية القيام بذلك
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
الليلة أنا  يمكن أن يبلغ
الشعب الأمريكي والعالم
أن الولايات المتحدة قد نفذت
عملية قتلت أسامة بن لادن
زعيم القاعدة
الأجنبي ،
وأعتقد أننا استرخينا كثيرًا وكان
الأمر سيئًا لم يكن علينا أبدًا
السماح لتلك الخلافة بالحصول
أقيمت في الجزء الشمالي من أه
العراق ولم يكن لها أي معنى أه وانظروا
ما فعلته مع سوريا وأعني أننا ما
زلنا نقاتل أعني أن لدينا قوات
هناك لا يزال الناس يموتون بعض
الدول
شجعت
عشرات الآلاف من  المقاتلون الأجانب
للقدوم إلى سوريا
من أجل
إسقاط
النظام السوري ، لقد
استخدموا الحدود
بين العراق وسوريا ، وهذا أحد
الأسباب الرئيسية
لنجاح
الإرهابيين في العراق ،
وكنا نتمنى
ألا يكون هؤلاء الأشرار سيئين للغاية ، وإذا  كنا لطفاء ،
سيكونون لطيفين فقط ، لذا سنخبز لك
كعكة في عيد ميلادك وتعال وسنحصل
جميعًا على قطعة من الكعكة
[موسيقى]
ما فعلناه هو أننا
خلقنا
أه
السيد الزكاري و  داعش وهذا
سمح للقتل والفوضى
والإرهاب بالانتشار في جميع أنحاء
البلاد وسمح لداعش بأن يرعى
رأسه لعقد آخر
وأن يؤسس خلافة
الآن لحسن الحظ من قبل الولايات المتحدة
والمقاتلين الدوليين والعراقيين لقد
قضوا على الخلافة
لكنهم تمكنوا من ذلك.  لم يتم القضاء على داعش ، لا
يزال هذا عاملاً
لم يكن فاشلاً ، حيث بلغ نصيب
الفرد من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي
في العراق اليوم خمسة أضعاف ما
كان عليه في عام 2003 ، حيث
انخفض معدل وفيات الأطفال ،
وأصبح متوسط ​​العمر المتوقع أطول ،
لذا
أصبح العراقيون اليوم أفضل حالًا مما كانوا عليه في عهد
صدام.  حسين
[موسيقى]
القاعدة
حسنًا ، ليس لدى الإسلاميين السنة
برنامج أسلحة نووية
ولا لديهم
برنامج أسلحة بيولوجية كيميائية كما تفعل إيران الحقيقة هي
أن القدرة على إلحاق
أضرار جسيمة تتجاوز رعب 9  11
ولكن أكبر بكثير
من ذلك يذهب إلى البلد الذي
يطور كل من القدرة الإرهابية
وسلاح الدمار الشامل ولهذا
السبب إيران
هي التهديد المركزي
الأجنبي
[موسيقى] [موسيقى
]
أجنبية [موسيقى] [موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
[موسيقى  ]
لا يزال علينا أن نلعب دورًا في التأكد
من عدم عودة العراق أو أفغانستان
مرة أخرى إلى قاعدة عمليات
للإرهاب
أه للأسف عندما غادرنا العراق
وسيطرت الشيعة
قاموا بإقصاء السنة من
العمليات في الحكومة من
العسكريين
والسنة  سرعان ما انضم إلى داعش
وأنشأ القوة التي عادت
إلى العراق
وكان على الولايات المتحدة العودة
للتأكد من أن داعش لن تسيطر على
العراق ،
وعلينا التأكد من أننا لا نرتكب
نفس الخطأ في أفغانستان
[موسيقى]
أجنبي
هل يؤسفني ذلك نعم ، نعم سيدي
نعم أنا
آسف لذلك لأن
أربعة آلاف أو أكثر من مواطنيي
لقوا حتفهم لا أستطيع أن أتخيل عدد العراقيين آه
الوضع أفضل إلى حد ما الآن ولكن داعش
ما زال موجودًا
أنا مرعوب  مع أولئك المرتبطين بالعراق
وأشعر أنه ديون أنا مدين لمواطنيي ،
ولا أشعر بالأسف لأنني
لم أفعل ذلك في عام 1991. أتمنى
ألا يكون لي أي شيء حيال ذلك في
كل وفاة  حدث في العراق من
الجانب العراقي ومن الجانب الأمريكي ومن الجانب
البريطاني
وأطراف ائتلاف الأطراف الأخرى
أشعر أنني أتحمل بعض المسؤولية
عن
عدم الشعور بالرضا
ولا أعتقد أن هناك
اهتمامًا لفهم 9 11 جيدًا
بعد الآن  أعتقد أنه من العام الماضي لأجيال اليوم
القادمة ،
لا أعتقد أن دروسهم التي تعلمناها
قد تم أخذها على محمل الجد ولإثبات
وجهة نظري أننا ما زلنا لا نبلي بلاءً
حسنًا في الحرب على الإسلام الراديكالي ،
لا يزال بإمكاني أن أريكم بوكو حرام.  لا يزال بإمكاني أن
أريكم الفظائع ، لا يزال بإمكاني الذهاب
إلى أي بلد تريده وأظهر لك
أن الأمور أقل استقرارًا الآن
مما كانت عليه عندما غادرت الوكالة في
عام 2006. وأنا لا أمزح ، فنحن نعرف كيف
نلاحق الإرهابيين وأن  قتلهم
ولكن الشيء الوحيد الذي لم نعمل عليه
هو كيف نمنع
الإرهابيين من أن يصبحوا إرهابيين ، وهذا
شيء لم نركز عليه بنفس
القدر من النية لأننا
لا نتعلم دروسًا في أمريكا لقد
أحدثنا فوضى لقد قتلنا الكثير من الأشخاص
ونصف مليون شخص أسقطنا
قنابل حديدية على شمال فيتنام ولاوس
وكمبوديا أكثر مما أسقطناه في
الحرب العالمية الثانية
ولم نتعلم شيئًا ، لذا فإن
الإجابة على سؤالك هي أن الأمريكيين
لا يتعلمون أي شيء
أميركي يجب أن نطلق عليهم
الولايات المتحدة لفقدان الذاكرة
[موسيقى]
لك